pretty eyes yeah I like your pretty eyes
how's it goin bad my name is purity pass
and welcome back to chatter day prepare
what anyway I'm sorry I didn't make a
video yesterday at his didn't I'm time
for it so I thought I was going to do it
today instead and we're gonna eat some
candy then basically it's a bunch of
like weird Mexican candy that I never
even heard of and it's you should be
kind of spicy and disgusting now gonna
lie I do appreciate you sending food
discount it but it tastes like [ __ ]
but before anything else I want to say
thank you for all the responses and all
feedback on the apology video it's been
something that I've been bothering me
before but right like when I made that
video I was just so tired of it and I
just want to move on again
and I don't know so so don't worry about
me I'm totally fine
but I really appreciate I know that so
yeah which candy should I go with first
Eliana engine la pickle
they look like this it looks like a baby
tongue mixed down into tiny pieces of
sand pretty much all right
chess press that was really good
I'd give it that I give that up nine out
of ten it's really good it tastes like
shampoo I'm serious I don't I think
someone from Mexico is trolling me and
send me shampoo and see if I would
actually eat it this tastes exactly like
shampoo all right next one you can't get
worse from neck just can't all right
these are called pellon meaning you
can't see that but it's okay don't worry
about it you have problem with your
eyesight I get it
I think they'd send me glue doesn't this
look like glue how do I even write
I don't get it anyway sniffing glue
don't do that at home oh it's disgusting
if you I don't you football not see this
but if you have Trooper phobia this is
[ __ ] disgusting
all right chess but ah [ __ ] this up with
it first like a champ oh now I get to
this tastes like tomato sauce mixed with
dicks so pretty good I give it a 8.5 out
of 10 all right these are called pica
fish yeah flavoured gummy with chili and
sugar should be [ __ ] good I was a
slimy [ __ ]
ah sorry
why Mexicans why do you do this
that was actually the best one so far
I'm not even joking like this actually
tastes like candy next up we have the
van log a latte
I'm gonna guess that vero Ella what this
means very poo because this this looks
like poo here we go sorry it looks like
someone [ __ ] on a stick and send it to
me thank thank you for doing that
yeah I don't know I haven't tried [ __ ]
but it tastes like folded [ __ ] it's
pretty good not out of time now I am
blood there we go
you probably you probably think that
after here it can't get worse now for
this if you guys ate all the bad candies
we have this allamanda Alabama
it's from Oh bless condor heights time
they left claim the left foot so it has
milk in it candy from mexico with milk
probably shouldn't eat this
all right this is what it looks like I'm
gonna reshape it into a penis so it
becomes more desirable I don't know
about you bros but I'm really sensitive
and stopping things like this in my
mouth
like I'd rather put it in my bot I'm not
even jumping that sounded really weird
take that take that back ah this is
actually not bad
holy [ __ ] good job thanks again coconut
real a total volume a roll of coconut
with the milk in them that's so good
can't wait to eat this sorry I know
oh [ __ ] me this smells really bad
it smells like your mama's nipples sorry
sorry your mom is watching I mean your
mama's perfumes and it smells really
good so you get out of trouble breaths
all right it's not bad it's just I said
the idea in my head that it's coconut
and milk from Mexico I just crossed me
anyway thank you for watching again
thanks for all the support on everything
you do really especially lately when I
felt like I needed it I need you rose so
it really shines brightest of my day
like um like a like a rainbow in a bad
weather that clears up blue clouds
should be a poet um stay awesome thank
you for being awesome and my my nostril
school say goodbye in Morse code
nostrils don't say that
oh I'm sorry thousand bar caramel
activate